we're getting a couple questions about
being a speaker so estaban saying how do
I start becoming a paid speaker kylus is
asking how do you evaluate speakers who
are coming in so in terms of being a
speaker you do a lot of speaking
obviously as part of what you do you've
hired speakers to come in and speak at
your events what are your thoughts on
people getting into the paid speaking
business in their evolution advice to
help them out yeah I think um I think
the parasocial is is really incredible
here so I think um if you want to become
a paid speaker and I think it's
fantastic and obviously it could be
pretty lucrative again I think number
one you need to have in this case the
product is you so you are the product so
what's your idea what's your point of
view what are you what do you want to be
famous for and it could be you know
you've done I haven't talked a lot and
he goes to speaking conferences about
entrepreneurship and he's now famous for
that he's a brand and I think you know
what is what is your number one what is
your product what is your big idea is
you what's your point of view and then
the next question yourself is why you
different how do you differentiate
yourself because again you know again
it's a crowded marketplace it's a noisy
marketplace you want to be different and
then I think once you've determined
there then you gotta build your profile
and the great news about social is the
audience can come to you so you know if
you were talking about women in business
or you're talking about inclusion or
you're talking about you know breaking
through the glass ceiling whatever it is
or or exporting in terms of how what are
the lessons learn if you're a u.s.
business you want to export it to Europe
and Asia whatever it is you will find
something where there is the good news
is there'll be thousands of people out
there who want to hear your story again
and then when you do do speaking I'd say
kind of how do you get how you amplify
the message and we've talked about this
before in former broadcaster
social media I think that's a brilliant
way to build a following build your
brand build build your fame and the
audience will come and then you you know
you get things like DMS where people pop
up and say we'd like you to come and
speak at this conference and I think
with these things you should kind of
test drive it what I'd advise then is
develop some really compelling stories
and again when you stand up there you
want to tell her most of all the
authentic tell him your story and again
put yourself in that you know kind of
what we said put yourself in the shoes
of the audience and obviously you know
it's a big conference two thousand
people or a two hundred people or even
20 people you want to kind of think how
do I make this really interesting for
the audience what it slightly beyond
their mind and what parts of my story
are going to kind of jump out for them
and make this memorable because because
again the amazing thing is we probably
all go to conferences and Evan yeah you
must have gone to thousands of
conferences the question you ask
yourself how do you become memorable
how do people talk about your story that
you present it and they share that with
your friends and then you have a
movement you have a following and
literally I know the case I quote about
someone I went to see speak 10 years ago
and they blew me away
and that could be you so I think I do
think it starts of the basics about the
kind of big idea the product the product
is you build your social kind of media
following have a strong point of view
and you will find then that you'll get
booked on and you can do stuff that I'm
not a big fan of it and I think it's
likely to be disintermediated there's
all these speaker marked and agencies
that kind of book speakers and they take
a commission and all that sort of stuff
and a lot of famous people and
celebrities use through their agents
these speaker marketing agencies but I
think the way you know the reality of
kind of the social media world has sort
of changed that forever but what you
might want to do is when you get a bit
of a following if you did want to do
something around
you know engage in an agent and one of
these sort of speaker marketing agencies
there's plenty of you know if you go to
Toronto there's probably a dozen speak
them up an agency's their New York
they're all over the place but again
they will have and the way they do it so
companies like us we're doing sage
summit we want to book the speaker we
want them talking about you know maybe
general entrepreneurship or overcoming
adversity or exporting or honey get
ready to grow and scale your business
from being a star to scale-up
whatever the theme is they'll go we have
the kind of playbook of who we got our
books it's always like an actor sort of
agent
they've got who's who's got these sort
of skills to poop and address this and
then they'll book you in there but I
think you know this is because this is
very personal and the product is you I
think you should take control of that
and I'm always my advice will always I'm
very reticent for you to sort of this is
a bad word but sort of prostitute a
brand out there were lots of different
people so they dilute you I think you
want to be you know truly is still being
congruent be authentic and be you and
and then people will come to love you if
you've got a compelling idea a big
vision and you tell it in a great story
Wow
you will make yourself memorable I think
to Stevens Point the gatekeepers are
disappearing you know those people who
you have to go through them to get any
opportunities it's disappearing those
speaker houses the people who like you
need their approval to get anything done
it's going away which creates a lot of
opportunity for a lot of people but you
have to be good and you get good by
practicing you got to practice like if
you want to be a speaker I would be on
YouTube every day practicing your speech
practicing answering questions
practicing practicing practicing
practice your talent should be obvious
this is great clip that we included on
one of her videos of mmm the rapper
prank-calling a radio station you said
his name was like I'm John from Miami
something like that
and and he said hey can I rap for you
and he that's a rap and LL Cool J was on
a station at DJ's realization and they
said man you're really good
like you should consider doing this as a
career John from Miami and they didn't
know his mmm but and later on he said it
was Eminem and he pulled their leg and
the thing is like his talent was obvious
so is your talent obvious Steven talked
about he went to go see a speaker 10
years ago and like blew him away are you
doing that to your audiences if if you
make a youtube video and the people who
watch it are blown away they're gonna
share it they're gonna tell their
friends about it you're gonna get booked
on speaking gigs and the more you do
that the more content you create that
blows people away the more your profile
is going to rise the challenge is for
most people you're not quite good enough
yet you need to practice more you got to
get to that point where you can blow
people away since the market is so wide
open you got people around the world now
you're competing with that you have to
get really good and so it's never been
easier which is great but you have to
put in the work to get there and so I
would be starting a YouTube channel
immediately I'll be posting daily
content work work work
I was not a great speaker when I started
but I did 4,000 YouTube videos right
like you you better get better after
doing something 4,000 times right
anything if you're practicing basketball
if you take 4,000 shots you better get
better at taking that shot it's hard not
to and so I think getting out there and
practicing so that when people see you
they are blown away is going to be your
ticket and much more than trying to go
to an agency or these these houses
because the gatekeepers are going away
to Stevens Point I agree